so a simplistic way of looking at this
dispute is that players want changes
made to the economics of baseball while
owners want to keep the status quo what
do you think the players see as broken
well the players salaries over the last
four or five years have actually
declined by four or five percent and at
the same time franchise values
sponsorship revenue tv revenue has gone
up so i think they probably want to
recalibrate that situation what's taking
place actually scarlett is that
the owners have really kind of
manipulated the structure of the payment
to young players meaning the transition
from minor league to major league
baseball and the the restrictive
elements of that process and they've
actually been able to bring the cost
down that plus
analytics and being more efficient in
spending and targeting players has
resulted for young players a real
decrease of course you're hearing about
you know all these big deals with the
veteran players they're being paid well
where the problem is with the young to
middle players so isn't this a problem
in minor league baseball more than it is
in major league baseball no because
that's okay but it's a transition from
minor league to major league and sending
guys back to the miners that has really
kept the prices down of the young
players so they want some modifications
and restrictions left in terms of how
fast people can be unrestricted versus
restricted okay so no business of
baseball can be done right now during
this work stoppage but they do have some
time right because spring training
doesn't begin until early next year so
there's a couple of weeks or maybe a
couple of months to get things going
does that lack of urgency
favor one side or the other well i think
all these things are going to come down
to to a lot of time pressure i do think
it was a good move by the league to lock
out because i think what it's going to
do is put pressure to negotiate and i'm
sure what the league and the players
want to do is get this resolved before
games are not played and there really is
a work stoppage so i think this is an
attempt as a major league baseball
manfred said to accelerate the
negotiation process it will be a tough
and contentious uh process and uh but
these things typically kind of go down
to the last minute got it there's a
distinction by the way between a lockout
and a strike a lockout is when
management which is owners in this case
uh initiate the work stoppage and a
strike is when labor the players here
decide that they're not going to work
how does that change how we the public
thinks about who's to blame here yeah i
think it leaves a bad taste in
everyone's mouth to begin with right and
if you go back to 1994 when there was
the last work stoppage it took 10 years
that was a player strike right yes that
was a 10 years to get back to the
attendance so again this isn't a winning
situation for players or owners you want
to get this done as quick as you can and
i think the the lockout is an attempt to
bring people to the table we'll see if
it works okay one argument that i keep
hearing major league baseball owners
make is that the players have the best
deal in pro sports they kind of bring
that point up over and over again does
that even really matter because the
players don't straddle different leagues
they play one sport and that's baseball
so they're comparing it to what they
think it should be or what it could be
or what it might once have been not
comparing it to what football players
have or what hockey players or
basketball players have right if i was a
major baseball player i'd say i'm the
only guys that do 162 games and have the
longest season in sport so you're right
every sport is slightly different and
again what the problem right now is the
inequity between the established players
they're making a lot of money but
everybody else is kind of lagging behind
that's interesting then is there a lot
of unity within the players association
then well that'll be part of the the
process of you know am i thinking of
myself am i thinking about the lower
scale players or am i thinking about the
super stars and that's always a tension
point with every labor deal
what is max scherzer thinking about
because he's a pitcher a free agent made
a big signing with the new york mets
just days before uh the lockout began
and
he's also a top union representative as
well which i thought was kind of ironic
it really is he benefited probably by
the mets trying to make a statement
before the lockout trying to solidify a
few things on their end and then at the
same time he's one of those guys that
are extremely well paid you know what
will be his uh empathy for those younger
players who are trying to get their
payday it's a real balancing act so
george you studied poli sci brown right
yes okay so i'd like to you to place the
baseball dispute in a bigger context
labor unions kind of having a moment
right now in the u.s workers are
suddenly
experiencing the upper hand or at least
a better footing right now to negotiate
wages and negotiate benefits since
august 1st we've tabulated that some 40
companies uh workplaces across the us
have gone on strike which is pretty
notable this may not be a strike as we
discussed earlier
but it does speak to how workers feel
more comfortable and more emboldened now
than they did previously how do you
think the momentum behind organized
labor is feeding into what's happening
in baseball right now you know i'm not
quite sure because i think it's hard to
see
people strike or complain about the
money these people are making so i'm not
sure that really relates to the average
person i will say myself though when i
did a little research on the topic it is
stunning that the actual revenues for
players have gone down over the last
four or five years and the numbers have
really gone up for the owners so i
really do think an average person
looking on saying hey if the owners are
making more the franchises are making
more the players should actually make
more so it really does look from the
outside looking in that an adjustment a
more equitable adjustment needs to be
made and is that something that will the
owners are willing to do well we'll see
i'm sure they the owners like where they
are so i'm sure uh it's gonna they're
gonna probably give a little and the
question was how much will they give and
how much can the players get and where
does that all net down and these these
are contentious negotiations i mean
major baseball players and the owners
it's contentious they battle
and it's uh there's a lot of emotion in
it and you never know how these things
play out so it's interesting because it
seems like they're battling over what
has been for the last couple of years
because players feel that they've been
undervalued but this is a collective
bargaining agreement for the next what
five years so they need to kind of
project out what things are going to
look like in the coming years too right
because when they did this deal prior
the players didn't anticipate kind of
the i don't want to call them
manipulation but you might say the good
effect of management of the transition
from minor league to major league and
also the the dependence on analytics so
now
uh in their negotiation they're going to
have to react to that to buck the trend
got it got it